Let's move on to another trait. Osteogenesis
Imperfecta, OI. Sometimes known as Brittle Bone Disease.
Now, people with OI are born with defective
connective tissue. Or sometimes without the ability to
make it. Usually because of a deficiency
in collagen. You may have heard of collagen
before maybe even in commercials or something like
that but when we talk about collagen it's
a huge and important structural protein in your
cells. It's kind of what makes your skin
so pliable and durable all at the same
time, it serves many important structural purposes. In the
case of Osteogenesis Imperfecta it doesn't work the
way it normally should. Now the incidence of OI
is about one in every 20,000 live births.
Let's take a look at our fictional individual Sadie
who has a European American background. And
here is a fictional pedigree of Sadie's family.
Here we see that Sadie is, is not affected by OI, but her brother, her mother,
her maternal uncle and her maternal grandmother
are all affected by Osteogenesis Imperfecta. Now just
like we've done for the last two traits
before we get into the genetic cause here,
first I want you to tell me a little bit about
the inheritance pattern of OI. Basing on the pedigree shown here,
what you've learned about inheritance patterns, I want you to tell
me if you think that this trait resembles an autosomal, sex linked
or maternal inheritance pattern. And then I want you to identify
whether or not you think it's dominant, or recessive. If you
have any trouble answering this, you can go back and check
out lesson five where we first learned about pedigrees and this kind
of dominance.